hemos visto ya un número razonable de
reacciones ácidas y de reacciones
básicas Así que simplemente vamos a
escribir alguna de ellas para repasarlas
y vamos a ver si podemos encontrar un
patrón general justo en todo lo que
vamos a trabajar el día de hoy aunque
muchas de esas reacciones podrían no ser
tan nuevas para ti empecemos si tenemos
por ejemplo floruro de hidrógeno es
decir hf h y la F con otro color
y este voy a decir que está en una
solución acuosa y bueno cuando está en
una solución acuosa a lo que me refiero
es al ácido fluorídrico el cual sabemos
que es un ácido débil es decir no se
disocia por completo así que esto me
está diciendo que estamos en equilibrio
y recuerda que estamos hablando de algún
tipo de equilibrio Eso quiere decir que
las concentraciones no forzosamente son
iguales y bueno este hidrógeno se
disocia entonces me va a quedar por aquí
okay el cual va a tener una carga
positiva y va a estar en una solución
acuosa de hecho en realidad sabemos que
se une a otra molécula del agua y forma
el hidronio y a esto le voy a agregar
déjame ponerlo con este color mi ion de
fluor el cual es un I negativo y está
también en una solución acuosa y para
que entiendas muy bien de qué estamos
hablando ahora Déjame escribir por aquí
abajo otra reacción justo por aquí para
que puedas ver el patrón general y
entiendas muy bien a qué me refiero se
me ocurre escribir la reacción ácida del
amonio Así que vamos a tomarnos por aquí
al
nh4
nh4 positivo lo cual es amonio o dicho
otra manera amoníaco con un hidrógeno
extra y vamos a poner también que está
en una solución acuosa y este de aquí va
a estar en equilibrio con uno de estos
hidrógenos el cual se disocia también en
una solución acuosa y luego tenemos
amoníaco es decir
nh3
nh3 y este también en nuestra solución
acuosa y ahora justo estas dos describen
una reacción en equilibrium pero
implican que estamos tratando con ácidos
débiles si tomas un ácido estás
produciendo hidrógeno que al menos eso
es lo que dice la definición de arrenius
de un ácido si miras la definición de
brosten lobry tomas el ácido y este está
donando protones a la solución está
donando protones al agua alrededor del
ácido y es una forma de describir esto
como un ácido ahora sabemos que es un
ácido débil Así que esta reacción va en
dos direcciones por lo que podemos
escribir la misma reacción esencialmente
como una reacción básica en vez de decir
que el ácido fluorhídrico es nuestro
ácido podríamos decir Oye qué tal si
empezamos con una anón de fluor Así que
lo pondré con su respectivo color
empecemos con un anion de fluor el cual
es un ion negativo es decir solamente
tengo un fluor negativo aquí el cual
también va a estar en una solución
acuosa y y este a su vez va a estar en
equilibrio y ojo antes de proseguir
quiero recalcar lo siguiente esta ahora
es una reacción básica es decir estoy
considerando esto como una base la cual
va a incrementar la concentración de
hidróxido Así que lo que podía querer
hacer es agarrar algún hidrógeno del
agua bueno el cual está en una solución
acuosa lo puede hacer Y entonces al
tomar el hidrógeno en qué se va a
convertir Bueno pues se va a convertir
en fluoruro de hidrógeno o ácido
fluorídrico así que por aquí voy a poner
mi h y con el mismo color voy a poner la
f ya tengo fluoruro de hidrógeno y bueno
este va a estar en mi solución acuosa y
ahora La pregunta sería Pues de dónde
tomo este hidrógeno y Bueno realmente lo
toma de una de las moléculas que rodean
a este fluoruro por lo tanto mi molécula
que era H2O ahora después de tener un
hidrógeno menos me va a quedar oh oh men
es decir hidróxido
Oh men el cual ahora va a estar en una
solución acuosa y ahora es que estas dos
se pueden ver de una manera distinta
fíjate bien en la de arriba este el
ácido fluorídrico está donando un
hidrógeno y bueno lo dona al medio
circundante para quedarse solamente con
un añón fluoruro mientras que en la de
acá abajo bueno es inicialmente está
creando una molécula de hidróxido a
partir del medio circundante así que de
alguna manera se ve esto bastante básico
pero si piensas en esto estas dos
reacciones son lo mismo es decir podrías
fijarte en esta y decir Bueno si
solamente voy en esta dirección es decir
para acá esto debe de reaccionar con
alguna molécula aleatoria de hidronio o
un protón independiente fuera de aquí y
después bueno Esto podría formar el flu
fluro de hidrógeno Pero sabemos que el
hidrogo no está simplemente sentado en
el agua esperando a que esto pase no
está sentado en todas partes Así que
cada vez que tomas la reacción inversa
es decir esta de aquí cada vez que vas
en esta dirección este no forzosamente
tiene que agarrar el hidrógeno de un h3
Oh lo puede tomar del agua del h2 Oh y
entonces tendrías esta reacción de aquí
por lo tanto estas dos son reacciones
equivalentes y con esta misma idea
podríamos hacer lo mismo acá abajo
podríamos decir en esta parte de aquí
abajo que si intercambiamos el amonio
por el amoniaco Y empezamos ahora con el
amoniaco
nh3 en una solución acuosa Okay y
decimos que este está en equilibrio con
lo siguiente Pero ojo date cuenta que el
amoníaco es una base estamos empezando
con una base débil e Imagínate que va a
agarrar de su medio circundante es decir
del agua que está alrededor un hidrógeno
para formar el nh4 el
nh4 el cual tiene un signo positivo Y
también vamos a decir que está en una
solución acuosa ya tenemos el amonio Y
de dónde tomó este hidrógeno Bueno pues
seguramente lo tomó de una molécula del
agua que estaba a su alrededor por lo
tanto esa molécula del agua se va a
convertir en un Oh negativo Oh negativo
en una solución acuosa pero date cuenta
de lo siguiente Esta es una reacción de
una base débil mientras que esta es una
reacción de un ácido de un ácido débil y
sin embargo estas dos expresiones son
equivalentes estas dos ahora con todo
esto probablemente ya hayas visto la
relación justo por aquí el amonium es un
ácido débil Mientras que el amoníaco es
una base débil y Cuál es la diferencia
entre los dos Bueno pues solamente un
hidrógeno simplemente una H por ejemplo
aquí arriba el ácido fluorídrico era un
ácido débil mias que la anón de fluor es
una base débil y Cuál es la diferencia
entre los dos solamente un hidrógeno son
diferentes por un hidrógeno Así que
déjame bajar la pantalla para explicarte
bien lo siguiente y para esto déjame
escribir aquí ácido débil ácido
débil débil y bueno por acá voy a poner
la base débil Así que con este color
pondré base débil
débil y débil lleva acento y este
también y bueno nuestro primer ácido
débil si te acuerdas era el ácido
fluorídrico h y con este color voy a
poner la f la F y después la base debil
era cuando
arrojándole es por eso que siempre hay
una carga negativa justo por aquí el
hidrógeno sin su electrón es simple y
sencillamente un protón porque no tiene
neutrones y bueno la otra era nh4
recuerdas teníamos
nh4 por aquí positivo y cuando arrojamos
ese hidrógeno Bueno pues aquí nos iba a
quedar
nh3
nh3 es decir amoníaco y bueno Cuál es la
diferencia que presenta Pues date cuenta
de lo siguiente de aquí para acá lo que
estamos haciendo es quitando un
hidrógeno eso ya lo habíamos visto o
pensado de la otra forma de aquí para
acá lo que estamos haciendo es agregando
un hidrógeno Así que podría decirte que
tienes a estos dos tipos y son
conjugados esto de ha sido un largo
camino para introducirte a esta idea que
tienes un par conjugado y es más aquí el
ácido fluorídrico y el anón de fluor
estos dos son pares conjugados déjame
escribirlo Ah pares pares conjugados
conjugados es decir este y este y si te
preguntan Qué es un par conjugado que en
lo único que difieren es en un protón de
hidrógeno y por eso voy a ponerle aquí
un signo de más en un protón de
hidrógeno protón de hidrógeno De hecho
si te fijas estos de aquí son
exactamente iguales que estos de aquí
excepto por un protón de hidrógeno y no
más que un protón de hidrógeno eso es
muy importante porque tal vez algún día
podría hacerte la prueba de que te
enseñe dos moléculas que difieran por
dos hidrógenos y entonces no serían
pares conjugados por ejemplo podemos ver
aquí H H2O H2O y Oh negativo estos dos
son pares conjugados Por qué Porque la
única diferencia Es un protón de
hidrógeno dicho de otra manera este de
aquí si tú le agregas a un protón de
hidrógeno llegarías a este de aquí ahora
debes de tener cuidado porque si yo bajo
un poco la pantalla y te pongo lo
siguiente te pregunto el
h3o
h3o positivo y el Oh negativo y y el Oh
negativo esos dos son pares conjugados
Bueno pues podrías estar tentado en
decir sí si lo son porque este es muy
ácido y este es una base Así que es un
par conjugado pero no ten cuidado estos
dos no son pares conjugados porque hay
una diferencia de dos protones de
hidrógeno por lo tanto no son pares
conjugados par es
conjugados Ju gados ahora como no son
pares conjugados los voy a cruzar estos
no lo son Ahora si te preguntas cuál es
y déjame Borrar esto de aquí si te
preguntas Cuál es el par conjugado del
h3o positivo h3o positivo Bueno pues de
igual manera si le quitamos un protón de
hidrógeno vamos a llegar al H2O a la
molécula del agua esta sería su base
conjugada y de hecho déjame subir un
poco la pantalla porque quiero
introducir una nueva definición o una
nueva forma de ver a estos dos de aquí
porque ahora lo que quiero que veas es
lo siguiente dentro de cada par
conjugado vas a tener un ácido conjugado
y una base conjugada y déjame ponerlo
Aquí vamos a quitar esto de aquí y voy a
poner aquí ácido conjugado
conj gado y también Aquí voy a quitar
esto de aquí y vamos a ponerle aquí base
conjugada y ahora sí hasta te puedes
preguntar si yo tengo que el ácido
fluorídrico es un ácido bueno Cuál va a
ser su base conjugada entonces si te
deshaces de este hidrógeno vamos a
llegar a que su base conjugada va a ser
una Neon de fluor o por ejemplo puedes
decir tengo como base al amoniaco al
amoníaco Cuál va a ser su ácido
conjugado le agregamos un protón de
hidrógeno llegamos a este de aquí es
decir al amonio Así que podréis llamar a
este también un ácido conjugado y mucho
ojo veremos que en realidad no tienes
que estar usando ácidos débiles ni bases
débiles algo podría ser un ácido
conjugado o una base conjugada y no
forzosamente debe de ser o muy básico o
muy ácido Y es más vamos a verlo con un
ejemplo si bajamos un poco todo esto Ah
Déjame llegar justo por acá e Imagínate
que me tomo no sé se me ocurre tomarme
cloruro de hidrógeno
hcl sabemos que este es un ácido fuerte
y si esencialmente nos quitamos este
hidrógeno que tenemos aquí Bueno pues
vamos a llegar a un anón de cloro estás
de acuerdo solamente quitamos el protón
de hidrógeno Así que simplemente este
anón de cloro negativo va a ser su
conjugado Cuál es el ácido conjugado de
esta anón de cloro Bueno pues va a ser
el ácido clorídrico
o también te podría decir si te doy
ácido clorídrico y te pregunto Cuál es
su base conjugada Bueno solamente nos
deshacemos de este de este protón de
hidrógeno Y entonces su base conjugada
va a ser este anón de cloro ahora lo que
sí sabemos es que el ácido clorídrico es
un ácido fuerte si yo pongo por ejemplo
aquí al ácido clorídrico en una solución
acuosa sabemos que va a pasar de hecho
esta es la primera reacción que vimos es
una de las reacciones que más hemos
visto nosotros vamos a llegar a que como
es un ácido fuerte se disocia por
completo se disocia primero en protones
de hidrógeno los cuales se unen a una
molécula del agua esto en una solución
acuosa y bueno a esto le vamos agregar
aniones de cloro también en una solución
acuosa ahora el hecho es que se disocia
completamente por lo tanto esta no es
una reacción en equilibrio esto implica
que si tenemos esto de aquí no va a
regresar para acá o dicho otra manera
este de aquí es menos básico que el agua
déjame atraparlo este de aquí va a ser
menos básico que el agua es decir no
tiene la tentación de agarrar estos
protones de hidrógeno del agua y así
regresar al ácido clorídrico por lo
tanto no va en esta dirección en esta
dirección no va esta reacción Así que
este anón de cloro o ion negativo de
cloro va a ser la base conjugada y
déjame ponerlo así la
base conjugada
con jugada entre comillas Okay este va a
ser la base conjugada del ácido
clorídrico y bueno lo pongo entre
comillas porque No necesariamente quiere
decir que este sea una base y creo que
es muy necesario aclarar muy bien Esto
si yo me tomo por aquí un anón de cloro
Okay en solución acuosa y a este le
agrego protones de
hidrógeno protones de hidrógeno esto no
nos va a dar esto no nos va a dar ácido
clorídrico por lo que podemos concluir
que realmente Este no es una base no es
una base Aunque aquí le estemos llamando
una base conjugada entre comillas lo
consideramos la base conjugada del ácido
clorídrico
Y es que generalmente cuando tratamos
con ácidos fuertes como el ácido
clorídrico si tengo una gran
concentración de aniones de cloro en el
agua una concentración grande de estos
estos no van a estar tentados de tomar
estos hidrógenos del agua es decir no
van a cambiar los hidrógenos actuales o
la concentración de hidróxido en el agua
ya que estos aniones de cloro no quieren
tomar nada del agua por lo tanto son
menos básicos que el agua entonces si
tienes una sopa supongamos en la que que
metemos agua y muchos aniones de cloro
su pH va a seguir siendo siete su pH va
a ser igual a 7 Aunque tengamos una
concentración tremenda de aniones de
cloro no sé supongamos que tenemos 10
molar de estos su pH seguirá siendo
siete porque no va a cambiar el pH de la
solución y Bueno claro estos aniones de
cloro déjame escribirlo por aquí en una
solución acuosa Aunque Obviamente si
pones ácido clorídrico en una solución
acuosa esto cambiará porque vas a estar
vertiendo todos estos protones de
hidrógeno en nuestra solución así que en
general creo que puedes recordarlo
Aunque pienso que tal vez es más sentido
común Ah déjame bajar un poco la
pantalla para escribirlo de todas
maneras el punto es que la base
conjugada
la
base
conjugada
conjugada de un ácido fuerte de un ácido
fuerte
ácido fuerte esta de aquí va a ser
neutra en agua es
neutra en agua esto es muy importante y
esto quiere decir que esencialmente no
impacta al pH esto de aquí quiere decir
que no cambia no cambia
el pH el pH dicho de otra manera puedes
decir que si tomas aniones de cloro más
agua más H2O Bueno pues esencialmente
vas a obtener aniones de cloro más
H2O no va a pasar nada con esta reacción
realmente no estás cambiando la
concentración ahora por otro lado si
nosotros pensamos y para eso déjame
subir un poco esta pantalla si ahora
pienso en lo que vimos sobre las bases
déjame subir un poco más esta pantalla
si yo me fijo en el fluor negativo este
de aquí y lo ponemos en agua primero
sabemos que es una base conjugada ahora
al agregarlo al agua qué es lo que va a
ocurrir justo esto de acá arriba si
ponemos fluor en el agua Bueno pues este
va a tomar algún protón de hidrógeno del
agua No necesariamente un montón de
hidrógeno pero agarra algo de hidrógeno
del agua que lo rodean en incrementa la
concentración de estos la concentración
del hidróxido va a aumentar Así que en
general lo que está haciendo en este
caso esta anón de fluor es haciendo la
solución más básica es decir estamos
aumentando el pH de la solución así que
siempre que tengas un ácido fuerte y es
más déjame bajar la pantalla para que lo
podamos escribir justo por acá abajo un
poco más un poco un poco más y por acá
vamos a escribirlo porque creo que esto
sería muy bueno que lo tuvieras por aquí
anotado para que en cuanto lo necesites
lo puedas recordar lo que quiero decirte
es lo siguiente Cuanto más fuerte es tu
ácido más débil va a ser su base
conjugada déjame escribirlo
Cuanto más
fuerte fuerte es tu ácido es el ácido en
entonces y déjame ponerlo justo así
entonces va a pasar lo siguiente más
débil es su base conjugada es su base
conjugada
conjugada y qué crees Esto va a ser lo
mismo al contrario es decir Cuanto más
fuerte es el ácido entonces más débil
Será su base conjugada y viceversa
Cuanto más fuerte sea la base y de
déjame ponerlo así
Cuanto más fuerte en este caso sea tu
base es decir lo contrario sea la base
entonces más débil será tu ácido
conjugado
entonces más débil es el ácido conjugado
Y esto es muy importante de hecho Sería
muy bueno que lo tuvieras en mente
que te lo aprendieras porque te va a ser
muy útil cuando resuelvas ejercicios por
ejemplo déjame borrar la pantalla porque
quiero que veamos algunos ejercicios
sobre ácidos y bases conjugadas Así que
borremos esta pantalla y vamos a
trabajar los siguientes ejercicios
Imagínate que empezamos con un ácido
déjame ponerlo con este color Aquí voy a
tener a mi ácido ácido y por acá a su
base
conjugada base
conjugada okay Ahora imagínate que
empezamos con el siguiente ácido y lo
padre es que realmente no me importan
los nombres Podría tener h n o 3 no
importa que sea y bueno su base
conjugada va a ser n o3 quito este
protón de hidrógeno y por lo tanto me
queda negativo O podría pensar tal vez
en lo siguiente no sé H 2
so4 para saber su base conjugada
Simplemente nos deshacemos de uno de
estos hidrógenos solamente de uno de un
protón de estos hidrógenos y me quedaría
hso4 negativo acabo de quitar un protón
de hidrógeno podemos ver otro ejemplo
más si yo me tomo
hbr Este es un ácido fuerte quito este
hidrógeno y me quedo solamente con un
anión de bromo ahora date cuenta Este es
un ácido fuerte cierto así que vamos a
tener aquí este anón de bromo que va a
ser neutral si lo ponemos en agua en
realidad no va a ser nada a pesar de que
lo estés llamando una base conjugada del
bromuro de hidrógeno y también podemos
ver lo contrario Ah si nosotros bajamos
un poco más esta pantalla y pensamos
ahora en lo siguiente yo me tomo por
aquí ahora al Oh negativo al Oh negativo
y te digo si te doy ahora esta base Cuál
va a ser su ácido conjugado bueno eso ya
lo vimos Esto es lo mismo que
H2O estamos aumentándole un protón de
hidrógeno si nos tomamos por aquí H2O
Cuál va a ser su ácido conjugado bueno
va a ser
h3o positivo y esto ya lo habíamos hecho
inclusive Me podría tomar otro no sé
hco3 este negativo y le agrego un protón
de hidrógeno entonces llego al h2
co3 y ahora este es neutro porque le
agregué un protón y ya está como sea
Espero no haber batido este caballo a la
muerte y que tú hayas entendido Qué son
las bases y los ácidos conjugados y todo
acerca de ellos nos vemos en el
siguiente
video